[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the oh
my god what the hell is this I just okay
so I've just seen the trailer for Sonic
the Hedgehog and honestly this film
looks very very bad video game movies of
course have a pretty dire reputation at
this point and yep I feel like the only
thing that Sonic should be doing right
now is running the hell away from this
movie pretty much everything in this
trailer fields very very off look never
mind
let's just watch it for ourselves
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
gotta go fast
[Applause]
20 minutes ago an energy surge knocked
out power across the entire Pacific
Northwest this needs someone who can
figure out exactly what we're dealing
with you're not suggesting room I think
you're suggesting we have no choice
what are you in charge here yes I am I'm
wrong
mommy charge allow me to clarify in a
sequential e ranked hierarchy based on
level of critical importance the
disparity between us is too vast to
quantify agent stone the doctor thinks
you're basic listen pal I don't know if
you realize I'm sorry major what was
your name benjoe nobody cares
[Music]
meow basically it looks like I'm gonna
have to save your planet
[Music]
you know but thank you for asking
whatever this creature is our job is to
security neutralize it see what makes it
tick
[Music]
look at this I took 9 million steps
today
stay in there to be quiet how much
longer I keep three even here do you
have your child in that Bank no I mean
yes it's a child but it's not mine it's
not your child
smells like bodies bringing an old ham
sandwich okay so a will credit paramount
with this that coin intro at the start
looks great but sonic looks like Papa
Smurf's dog and dr. Robotnik looks like
a cross between Hitler and Stalin now
growing up I was massively into Sonic it
was always kind of the cool character
that was a bit of an opposite to Mario
who was a fat plumber with a moustache
this little critter was just too cool
for school it was too fast to ever get
caught and the original games are
complete classics this just doesn't be
like that and it's pretty jarring to see
Sonic existing in our world to me Sonic
should be something that has its own
reality and I have no idea why they
didn't make this fully animated like say
The Incredibles or Shrek or you know
something with a unique aesthetic I
think that would have been far better
than trying to ground it in the real
world everything about the design just
seems off I mean he has human legs a
massive head and it's just and it's just
me or does gangster's paradise not come
to mind when you think about dr.
Robotnik who is making these creative
decisions Jim Carrey is in full 90s mode
and again it just seems off like Carrie
is a great actor and he's hilarious when
in the right role but honestly who would
cast him as dr. Robotnik especially the
nineties version of himself it just
seems so off and honestly he comes
across as irritating more than anything
else the CGI in this makes detective
Pikachu look like Avengers endgame and
the entire look and feel of it just
feels completely alien to what I'd
imagine a sonic movie to look like I
think when executives get the tone of
something wrong it shows they either
don't understand the source material or
don't care enough to actually look at it
and this feels like a mixture
I was really hoping for this to be good
which is why i haven't wailed in on it
as still images can be misleading but
man this looks bad I just wish they'd
stop trying to adapt video games unless
they have something like the Last of Us
because this isn't gonna work it's gonna
destroy everyone's career oh no Jim
Carrey who are just making a comeback as
well Oh obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film and if you think it
looks good then let me know why in the
comments below if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my full breakdown of Avengers
endgame which will be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who are
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]